can you talk about the differences
between financing your documentary work
and the narrative films you're now
financing
regarding financing for documentary
films versus The Narrative feature films
for decades it's been much easier to get
the money to make the documentary films
and the travel Adventure films they're
almost always financed ahead of time
either through grants but usually
through uh a fairly wealthy person that
is has some interest in the documentary
that's been very interesting to me so
that's why I've been working through
like Partners like Paul Perry and others
that have uh access to certain investors
that had a really Keen interest in uh
history topics or near-death experience
topics or art and so on and so they
would Finance these documentaries so I
didn't have to worry about that and that
was nice it's obviously that's the
critical thing for filmmaking it's
assuming you've got the great story and
the talent and the gear is you need the
money and everybody's looking for money
right at every level of filmmaking so
for documentaries I found that always to
be more lucrative I would just set a fee
for my services if it's for directing
and shooting or one of the other and so
usually I would come in as a associate
production company in itself and provide
the whole package of directing assisting
with producing shooting and editing so
I'd usually present a
a package of services for a certain
amount of money for the documentary and
then that would just be financed through
the uh the equity investment the person
that's connected to the documentary now
for feature films that's the trick
that's the hardest thing in the world is
to make a
successful feature film that gets its
money back and profit
I think the percentage is only five to
ten percent maybe only five percent of
independent filmmakers that actually get
their money back from a feature film and
make any money at all it's such a tiny
percentage So and I've found that to be
the case even after having
Decades of experience track record
things to show people you still have to
go out there and prove it raise the
money somehow through Equity financing
private investors for me that's the only
way we've gone so far we hope to get
into the next Echelon of filmmaking
where it's two three million four
million dollars then that becomes
something now associated with uh you
know offers to name actors that then you
can reserve their talent and then
negotiate with the banks for financing
or then you also can get money from of
course the rebates from certain
countries or States
for money you spend in their state or
their country that's very competitive
right now by the way and we could talk
about that more but but generally for
feature filmmaking it seems to be uh
uh more challenging absolutely even with
all the ideas and movies we've done
already everyone you start off with and
present to an investor
generally it's the return on investment
sheet that they're interested in and
it's so hard to do that because uh the
distribution model has changed so much
as we know in the last 20 years used to
be you could go in and do pre-sales for
a feature film obviously different
territories
and you could make money right before
you produce the movie on pre-sales but
now it's almost impossible for an
independent filmmaker to get pre-sales
or to get a minimum guarantee or
anything from a distributor unless you
have a name actor associated with it and
you already have kind of a track record
making money with your features so for
me it's it's just a big challenge you
know to get the funding it is for almost
every filmmaker to do a feature film
unless it's very low level of 50 000 or
less
that's an interesting topic too I don't
know if we have time to talk about it
but it has to do with uh there seems to
be now a train of thought with a lot of
people that are talking about this
Distributors too that make a movie for
fifty thousand dollars or less or make
it with your name actor Associated and
it's a million dollars two million
dollars plus it seems to be like there's
a dangerous landmined area between fifty
thousand to a million where it's a no
man's land and it's filled with all
kinds of uh possible places where you
can be blown up and not get your money
back
and uh that's because of uh
name actors are everything that's what
every distributor it can at AFM at
Berlin's Market you know it doesn't
matter what you come up with a story
they say who's in it is the first
question and who's in your movie
because they need to get a handle on it
who are they going to put the poster in
the trailer so on and so forth so but
some Distributors are saying well make
something that is uh actiony they use
that term actiony or horror genre based
or uh something like that martial arts
something these genres right for 50 000
or less I think we can definitely make
money on that so it's very strange model
right now in my mind why why can't you
do something in that half a million
dollar range and get your money back and
profit if you're a talented filmmaker
very challenging right now very
challenging almost
you're fighting the odds so much like I
said less than five percent will succeed
in that range
when looking for an investor
how do you know which investor will
withstand being able to not get their
money back
should the opportunity arise right with
the films that we've done since they're
micro-independent features uh usually me
included we go to friends or friends or
friends that uh have the wherewithal
to be able to put in money for points
and and usually uh film is is made under
an LLC for each film you have a limited
liability company and bank account and
you approach uh with your of your cell
sheets with your pitch deck and your
track record and if they're a friend
they already know this already so you
try to get them to buy in for uh ten
thousand dollars for a point or it might
be two points of value uh if they put
twenty thousand they get four points or
it depends on the structure of your
budget maybe they get just two points
but then as as you've probably heard
before usually the uh almost always the
deal is structured where you tell that
investor that they're going to get the
first money back plus 10 or 20 percent
on top of their investment before the
rest of the money is dispersed to the
other LLC members
so but your question again how do you
know which ones or what to say or what's
which ones are more appropriate
you know as long as you've got uh a
handful of uh investors that believe in
you and want to be part of this film
Adventure because that's what we tell
people we're involved with
we're not making this film to get uh
Rich we'd love to be able to strike it
rich but that's so rare and you don't
want to present a blue sky proposal to
somebody that's unrealistic so you have
to tell every a possible investor that
will definitely do our best to get that
money back plus some gravy on top of
that for you but your money is
completely at risk so you don't want to
go to people that
are really already fighting uh fighting
to pay their bills you know on a monthly
basis just would be completely unfair to
go to certain relatives or friends that
just don't have that cushion of money so
usually you know after making a film or
two a movie or two you already know the
people that uh
could lose that money they could lose
ten or Twenty Thousand no one wants to
but they couldn't it wouldn't be a
detriment to their lifestyle or health
or anything else but they you know they
they go into it with their eyes open
investors often want to come into a
movie because they like you they believe
in you they've been a friend for a long
time or family member they also want to
be associated with the adventure of the
film they believe in the topic sometimes
very strongly if it's a a big social
theme climate change some there's so
many different topics that you can find
people that are very passionate about
and they don't mind not losing it per se
but just saying that okay it's going to
a good cause you're going to get this
message out in this documentary or part
of your feature film story could be
about a social issue too so they want to
be associated with that cause that is a
little bit bigger than they are
and that's really the kind of people
usually that I I've been dealing with
over the last many many years
are people that sometimes if a person
puts in a certain amount of money they
they want to go on the production itself
and that's a big buzz it's a the juice
is in producing and shooting and when
you're doing movies some people get
excited about the editing
but I don't I don't really like editing
even though I'm very good at it I don't
like it at all because it's inside
and for me the I'm into filmmaking to
get out in the world and be get my hands
a little dirty uh in in these different
places and get immersed and that's of
course where the buzz is for most
filmmakers is in the production itself
and working with actors and and then the
editing is is something else it's a
tedious process over months uh and you
learn to almost
this doesn't hit the topic of investment
but you actually as a filmmaker you you
know when the film is done when you're
just so tired of it seeing it so many
times
over months and you almost not hate it
but you learn to almost say you know
you've taken too much of my time this
film is really good in the last few uh
weeks of a film it tends to be
diminishing returns I think most
filmmakers will tell you that you're get
into nitpicking on a certain word and a
certain scene or certain fraction of a
second to cut sooner that the audience
generally is not going to care about
these last minute little details that
you become obsessed with try not to as a
filmmaker try to get at least to 95
percent of what you wanted you'll never
get a hundred percent
you always know you could have done
something better in retrospect when you
watch your movies every time I see any
film I've ever done I know all the
mistakes I know all the things that were
very good about it and you always wish
that you could go back with more money
and time to do certain things again
so you just have to call it quits after
a while like a painter when does a
painter stop painting
how could we tell you know on a canvas
they know though like filmmakers know
off topic but I thought interesting